bun venit înapoi la înțelegerea informației și computației cuantice, numele meu este John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic
pentru educație la IBM Quantum. Aceasta este lecția eth din serie și este ultima lecție din
a doua unitate a seriei, care tratează algoritmii cuantici. Am discutat despre modelul de interogare al computației, inclusiv
algoritmii cuantici care oferă avantaje demonstrabile față de algoritmii clasici în cadrul acelui model. Am discutat concepte fundamentale legate de
algoritmii cuantici și cum putem măsura costul computațional, iar în lecția anterioară am discutat despre estimarea fazei și algoritmul lui Shor.
În această lecție vom discuta despre algoritmul lui Grover, care oferă un avantaj cuadratic al cuanticului față de
algoritmii clasici pentru așa-numitele probleme de căutare nestructurată, pe care le voi descrie odată ce intrăm în
lecție. Acestea sunt toate subiecte fundamentale privind algoritmii cuantici. Există și alți algoritmi cuantici,
precum și paradigme generale care unesc diferiți algoritmi cuantici și tehnici algoritmice cuantice, și
dacă ești interesat, te încurajez să consulți quantum algorithm Zoo, care clasifică algoritmii cuantici cunoscuți și include multe referințe
la articole de cercetare originale care au contribuit la dezvoltarea lor. Pentru această serie, totuși,
ne vom limita la fundamente și, începând cu lecția următoare, vom trece la un nou subiect, dar
mai întâi să vorbim despre algoritmul lui Grover. Iată prezentarea generală a lecției: vom începe cu o scurtă discuție despre
problema computațională pe care o vom aborda, și anume căutarea nestructurată. Intuitiv vorbind, poți
te gândi la problema căutării nestructurate ca la căutarea printr-o colecție de elemente care nu este sortată și nu a fost ordonată în mod util.
Apoi vom discuta algoritmul lui Grover, care este un algoritm cuantic ce oferă un avantaj cuadratic față de
algoritmii clasici, și vom detalia exact ce înseamnă asta în curând. O descriere foarte generală a
modului în care funcționează acest algoritm este că mai întâi există un pas de inițializare, iar apoi o operație la care mă voi referi ca
operația Grover este iterată de un anumit număr de ori și, în final, are loc o măsurătoare care dezvăluie un candidat
la soluția problemei de căutare. Voi explica ce este operația Grover și cum poate fi
implementată pe un calculator cuantic, iar apoi vom analiza această operație pentru a înțelege mai bine ce face și de ce este utilă pentru
căutare. A treia parte a lecției se referă la numărul de iterații
din algoritmul lui Grover sau, cu alte cuvinte, de câte ori trebuie aplicată operația Grover, presupunând că dorim
să maximizăm probabilitatea ca algoritmul să reușească să găsească ce căutăm, minimizând în același timp costul.
Vom începe cu problema de căutare unică, care este un caz special în care există exact o soluție pentru
problema noastră de căutare, iar apoi vom analiza ce se întâmplă când există soluții multiple. În final, voi încheia
lecția cu câteva remarci scurte despre algoritmul lui Grover și generalizările sale. Să începem cu
problema computațională pe care o vom aborda pe parcursul lecției. Mai întâi, cum facem de obicei, vom
lăsa Sigma să desemneze alfabetul binar și vom folosi această notație pe tot parcursul lecției, deci nu voi continua
să vă reamintesc. Să presupunem că avem o funcție f care mapează șiruri binare de o lungime oarecare n la
alfabetul binar. Presupunerea noastră este că putem evalua cu ușurință această funcție, de
exemplu poate avem un circuit Boolean pentru această funcție a cărei dimensiune este polinomială în n. Aceasta nu înseamnă că este
neapărat o funcție simplă în vreun sens sau că avem o înțelegere deosebit de bună a acestei funcții. De exemplu, poate avem un
circuit Boolean destul de complicat și dezordonat pentru calculul lui f, care ne permite să îl evaluăm pe diferite șiruri de intrare, dar nu are neapărat o
formă elegantă concepută să ne ușureze viața. Scopul nostru este să găsim o soluție,
adică un șir binar de lungime n care face ca f să se evalueze la unu. În general, aceasta este o problemă computațională foarte dificilă
sau cel puțin suspectăm că este foarte dificilă. În special, dacă intrarea este de fapt
descrierea unui circuit Boolean pentru calculul funcției f, atunci aceasta este o problemă NP-completă. O modalitate
de a formaliza această problemă este ca o problemă de interogare și, într-adevăr, pentru scopurile acestei lecții, este rezonabil
să ne gândim la această problemă exclusiv în contextul modelului de interogare, dar când ne gândim unde sau când ar putea apărea această
problemă în practică, este mai natural să ne gândim la f ca fiind calculat de un circuit Boolean,
după cum am văzut în lecția șase, deși putem conecta aceste două puncte de vedere prin construcția pe care am parcurs-o pentru a lua un circuit Boolean și
a-l converti într-un circuit cuantic pentru implementarea unei operații de interogare sau a unui gate de interogare. În orice caz, conceptual vorbind,
intrarea în problemă este această funcție f și căutăm o soluție, dacă există una, și dacă
nu există o soluție, adică f se dovedește a fi funcția constantă zero, atunci ieșirea corectă este să raportăm
că nu există soluții. Aceasta este o problemă de căutare nestructurată în sensul că nu există
nimic special în legătură cu f care să facă ușoară găsirea unei soluții. Nu este ca și cum am căuta
prin date care au fost deja ordonate sau încărcate într-o structură de date care facilitează căutarea și nu există nicio promisiune privind
funcția f care ar putea să ne ajute. O modalitate de a ne gândi la asta este că e ca și cum am căuta un anumit
număr de telefon într-un abonar față de a căuta un nume, ceea ce este mult mai ușor, presupunând că numele au fost
alfabetizate. În termeni practici, nu este cu adevărat vorba despre căutarea prin date
pe care tindem să le organizăm și să le stocăm într-un mod care facilitează căutarea. Este mai reprezentativ pentru căutarea
unei soluții la o ecuație complicată, de exemplu, sau poate căutarea combinației care deschide un
lacăt. Ca o paranteză, are sens să ne gândim la această problemă în contextul modelului de interogare, indiferent de cum ne-am simți
în legătură cu relevanța practică a acelui model. Desigur, în viața reală nu există oracole sau cutii negre, dar până când
nu aflăm altfel, circuitele Boolean complicate și misterioase sunt cam ca niște cutii
negre. Acum să ne gândim la algoritmi pentru rezolvarea acestei probleme de căutare nestructurată și vom face asta
în modelul de interogare, doar de dragul simplității. Dacă avem un circuit Boolean pentru funcția noastră în loc de o cutie neagră,
putem rula în continuare algoritmi de interogare pe el, dar desigur nu putem exclude posibilitatea că un nou algoritm
este descoperit pentru această problemă, care nu se bazează pe efectuarea de interogări, dar nu ne vom îngrijora cu privire la această
posibilitate. Mai întâi, o mică notație: numărul total de șiruri de intrare pentru funcția f este 2 la
WEBVTT
n mic, unde n mic este lungimea șirurilor de intrare pentru f, iar de acum înainte voi lăsa N mare să fie acest număr 2 la
n mic. Este destul de obișnuit ca oamenii să folosească o literă majusculă ca aceasta pentru a denota doi la puterea versiunii minuscule
a acelei litere. Vom vorbi destul de mult despre numărul N mare, deci aceasta va fi doar
convenabilă și va ajuta să menținem lucrurile un pic mai ordonate. Și din nou, această notație se aplică pe
toată durata lecției. Desigur, putem rezolva problema de căutare clasic, pur și simplu
iterând prin toate șirurile posibile de n biți în orice ordine alegem, evaluând f pe fiecare
dintre ele. Dacă găsim o soluție în orice moment, putem opri, dar în cel mai rău caz vom ajunge să evaluăm f pe fiecare
șir de intrare, deci aceasta necesită N, adică N mare,
interogări. Am putea alege să măsurăm costul acestei computații într-un mod diferit, nu doar în termeni de număr de interogări, dar numărul de interogări
reprezintă numărul de ori în care trebuie să evaluăm funcția f și este rezonabil să ne așteptăm că evaluările lui f vor domina costul
acestei computații. Acesta este de fapt maximul pe care îl putem face cu un algoritm determinist,
și din nou, acesta este în contextul modelului de interogare. Dacă am interogat fiecare șir de intrare
cu excepția unuia și f a luat valoarea zero pe toate până acum, cum putem fi siguri că ultimul
șir nu este o soluție? Și răspunsul este că nu putem, deci avem nevoie de toate N interogările în cel mai rău
caz. Am putea folosi și aleatorietatea, care poate oferi unele îmbunătățiri minore, cum ar fi reducerea
numărului așteptat de interogări necesare pentru a găsi o soluție când există una, sau am putea efectiv să facem un schimb între probabilitatea de corectitudine
și o reducere a interogărilor, dar oricum am analiza situația, vom avea nevoie în continuare de un număr de interogări liniar
în N. Deci, clasic vorbind, avem nevoie de un număr liniar de interogări, adică liniar
în N mare. Algoritmul lui Grover este un algoritm cuantic pentru căutare care face mai bine: necesită doar O mare din
rădăcina pătrată din N interogări. Acele interogări au loc în superpoziție, deci nu este magie, dar
este o îmbunătățire semnificativă față de ce este posibil clasic, și asta este ceea ce se înțelege prin avantaj cuadratic.
Poate fi transformat acest avantaj cuadratic al cuanticului față de clasic într-un avantaj real în sens practic?
Probabil nu prea curând, dar în viitorul îndepărtat, cine știe. Dar chiar dacă
algoritmul lui Grover nu duce niciodată la un avantaj practic pentru căutare, este totuși o parte importantă a
fundației algoritmilor cuantici, care merită cu siguranță înțeleasă. Înainte de a trece la algoritmul lui Grover propriu-zis, trebuie să
vorbim pe scurt despre așa-numitele gate-uri de interogare de fază. Mulți algoritmi cuantici din modelul de interogare sunt exprimați în mod natural
folosind gate-uri de interogare de fază și vom vedea că algoritmul lui Grover este un exemplu specific.
Să începem cu o privire rapidă asupra gate-urilor de interogare obișnuite. Pentru o funcție f de
forma despre care am vorbit, gate-ul de interogare UF este definit pe stările bazei standard așa cum este arătat pe
ecran, iar pentru superpozițiile stărilor bazei standard, acțiunea este determinată de liniaritate. Merită să ne reamintim
că dintr-un circuit Boolean pentru f putem în fapt construi un circuit pentru această operație UF la un cost care este
liniar în dimensiunea circuitului Boolean. Gate-ul de interogare de fază pentru f, pe de altă parte, pe care îl vom denota prin
numele ZF, funcționează astfel. În particular, acest gate operează pe
n qubiți mici spre deosebire de n plus unu qubiți mici și, practic, împinge automat valoarea funcției
în fază, în loc să aplice XOR pe valoarea de ieșire peste un qubit suplimentar, cum avem pentru
UF. Deci, dacă ne gândim la ce se întâmplă când folosim phase kickback pe un gate UF,
practic implementăm un ZF G. Avem nevoie de o stare minus și costă o
evaluare a lui UF, dar recuperăm starea minus și o putem folosi pentru următoarea dacă vrem, sau
o putem arunca. Deci acesta este ce este un gate de interogare de fază. Acum, dacă suntem
dați doar cu un gate de interogare de fază ZF și aceasta este singura modalitate prin care avem acces la funcția f, atunci nu putem de fapt
recupera un gate UF. Dar dacă avem o versiune controlată a lui ZF, atunci putem
construi un gate UF, și o las pe aceasta ca un exercițiu pentru tine.
Pe lângă gate-ul de interogare de fază pentru funcția f, vom mai avea nevoie de un gate de interogare de fază pentru funcția SAU de n biți,
sau altfel spus, funcția care ia valoarea zero când i se dă șirul de zero-uri și altfel
ia valoarea unu. Explicit, modul în care zor funcționează pe stările bazei standard este arătat
aici pe ecran. Acest gate nu are nicio dependență de funcția f, deci nu necesită
nicio interogare, iar o modalitate de a construi un circuit cuantic care implementează această operație este să facem ceva
similar cu ce am făcut pentru funcția f, cu excepția că începem cu un circuit Boolean care calculează funcția SAU pe
n biți. Acum că avem aceste gate-uri, suntem pregătiți să trecem la secțiunea următoare.
Acum vom discuta algoritmul lui Grover, începând cu o descriere a algoritmului. Începem prin inițializarea
a n qubiți mici, fiecare în starea plus, sau altfel spus, punem acești qubiți într-o superpozitie egală a tuturor
șirurilor binare de lungime n. Ceea ce vom face este efectiv să dirijăm starea acestor qubiți
spre o soluție, deci este intuitiv că începem în această stare pentru că nu știm nimic despre funcția f încă.
În acest punct, fiecare șir are șanse egale de a fi o soluție, și asta este reflectat de faptul că acești qubiți sunt într-o superpozitie egală a tuturor
șirurilor. Apoi iterăm; aplicăm în mod repetat operația Grover, care este cu adevărat inima
algoritmului, și o voi descrie într-un moment. Aplicăm această operație de un total de T ori, unde T este un număr întreg non-negativ,
dar acest număr nu este de fapt specificat de algoritm în sine. Trebuie să alegem T cumva și în secțiunea
următoare vom vorbi despre alegeri bune pentru T, dar deocamdată putem considera acest număr de iterații t ca
fiind arbitrar. Și în final măsurăm în baza standard, ceea ce ne dă un
candidat la soluție. Nu există nicio garanție că este o soluție, dar dacă alegem T bine, atunci
probabilitatea de a obține o soluție poate fi făcută mare. Și iată operația Grover
WEBVTT
în sine, pe care am numit-o G. Este o compoziție de operații, toate pe N qubiți, deci aceasta este o operație de N
qubiți. Mai întâi avem un gate ZF, sau altfel spus, un gate de interogare de fază pentru
funcția de intrare f, urmat de un strat de gate-uri Hadamard, iar apoi avem zor, care este gate-ul de interogare de fază pentru funcția SAU,
și în final un alt strat de gate-uri Hadamard. Deci vedem că o iterație din
pasul doi poate fi implementată printr-un circuit cu forma arătată pe ecran, și avem patru qubiți în cazul de față,
dar în general putem avea orice număr de qubiți. Un lucru important de remarcat este că avem nevoie de o singură interogare a lui f pentru a implementa G;
avem nevoie de o singură interogare pentru a implementa ZF și niciuna dintre celelalte operații nu are vreo dependență de f, deci nu necesită nicio interogare. Deci acest număr T care
reprezintă numărul de ori în care aplicăm G în pasul doi reprezintă și numărul de interogări de care
avem nevoie. Iată o modalitate tipică de a utiliza algoritmul lui Grover, dar cu siguranță nu este singura modalitate, așa cum am spus
înainte. Primul lucru pe care trebuie să-l facem este să alegem T, și vom discuta asta în secțiunea următoare.
Indiferent de T pe care îl alegem, rulăm algoritmul lui Grover pentru T iterații și obținem un candidat la soluție
x. Nu există nicio garanție că x este cu adevărat o soluție, dar putem cheltui o interogare suplimentară pentru a verifica. Dacă avem o soluție, atunci putem
să o afișăm și să ne oprim, iar altfel putem fie să încercăm din nou, posibil cu o altă alegere a lui T,
dar nu neapărat, sau putem renunța și raporta că nu există soluții. Cum am spus înainte, aceasta
nu este singura modalitate în care algoritmul ar putea fi utilizat, dar aceasta este o modalitate naturală de a-l aplica la problema de căutare. Urmează să vedem ce face operația Grover
de fapt cu starea celor N qubiți asupra cărora acționează. Să ne gândim la cei n qubiți ai noștri ca
formând un singur registru pe care îl voi numi Q, doar pentru a alege un nume. Amintește-ți că primul lucru pe care îl facem în
algoritmul lui Grover este să punem Q într-o superpozitie uniformă a tuturor șirurilor de n biți și facem asta aplicând gate-uri Hadamard
pe n qubiți în starea de zero total. Apoi iterăm operația Grover G și
măsurăm. Va fi util să împărțim mulțimea tuturor șirurilor de n biți în două mulțimi: A zero și
A unu. A zero conține toate șirurile care fac ca f să se evalueze la zero, iar A unu conține toate șirurile care fac ca f
să se evalueze la unu. O altă modalitate de a spune asta este că A unu conține toate soluțiile problemei noastre de căutare,
în timp ce A zero conține toate non-soluțiile. Ne vom interesa în special
de două stări cuantice: una este superpozitia uniformă peste toate non-soluțiile, adică ket A zero, și
cealaltă este uniformă peste toate soluțiile, iar aceea este ket A unu. Trebuie să subliniez că aceste definiții au
sens doar când aceste mulțimi sunt non-vide, deoarece altfel sumăm zero lucruri și împărțim la zero. Pe măsură ce parcurgem
această analiză a algoritmului lui Grover, vom face această presupunere. Putem afla foarte ușor ce
face algoritmul lui Grover când f este fie funcția constantă zero, fie funcția constantă unu, tratându-le ca cazuri speciale, dar o voi lăsa
pe aceasta pentru tine. Nu surprinzător, dacă fiecare șir este o soluție, vom obține într-adevăr o
soluție când măsurăm, și dacă nu există soluții, nu vom obține una, deoarece în acel caz nu există
niciuna. Dar pentru scopul acestei analize, vom presupune că ambele aceste mulțimi sunt non-vide, astfel încât aceste
definiții ale celor două stări să aibă sens. Apropo, aceasta este o notație destul de obișnuită:
ori de câte ori avem o mulțime finită non-vidă s, putem scrie ket s pentru a însemna superpozitia uniformă peste
elementele acelei mulțimi, exact ca și cum avem aici. Deci să adunăm aceste definiții astfel și vom vedea cum se conectează
la algoritmul lui Grover. Primul pas al algoritmului lui Grover este pasul de inițializare, care pune Q într-o superpozitie uniformă
peste toate șirurile de n biți și, pentru a da acestei stări un nume ușor de recunoscut, o voi numi
ket u; u este prescurtare pentru uniform. Este important pentru scopul analizei să notăm mai întâi că
această stare uniformă ket u este conținută în subspațiul generat de cei doi vectori ket a0 și ket
A1. În particular, dacă luăm combinația liniară a acestor două stări arătată pe ecran, vom obține ket
u. Acum cheia întregii analize este faptul că starea lui Q rămâne în
acest subspațiu bidimensional indiferent de câte ori aplicăm operația Grover. Deci totul se va reduce la
ce se întâmplă într-un subspațiu bidimensional. Acum să vedem ce face operația Grover și în particular ce
face vectorilor din subspațiul bidimensional generat de ket a0 și ket
A1. Este util să ne imaginăm că G este împărțit în două părți: una este gate-ul ZF
și cealaltă este gate-ul zor intercalat între două straturi de gate-uri Hadamard.
Iată definiția lui ZF de mai devreme și este destul de evident din acea definiție că acțiunea sa
asupra celor două stări ale noastre, superpozițiile uniforme ale non-soluțiilor și soluțiilor, este pur și simplu să pună un semn minus
în fața lui ket A1. Ei bine, ket a0 nu se schimbă, și asta este tot ce trebuie să știm
despre ZF pentru scopul acestei analize. Pentru a doua parte, care este
gate-ul Z sau intercalat între două straturi de gate-uri Hadamard, să începem prin a ne aminti cum este definit zor. O modalitate de a-l scrie
este cea arătată pe ecran. Aceasta este aceeași expresie ca mai înainte, iar o altă modalitate de a o exprima folosind notația
directă este astfel, și poți verifica această expresie gândindu-te la cum acționează operația de pe
partea dreaptă pe stările bazei standard. În particular, nu face nimic stării de zero total și fiecare
altă stare a bazei standard primește un semn minus, ceea ce este consistent cu definiția lui Z
sau. Deci, dacă intercalăm această operație între două straturi de gate-uri Hadamard, obținem o expresie similară, cu excepția
că în locul stării bazei standard de zero total avem acum superpozitia noastră uniformă ket u, și asta pentru că H tensorat
n transformă starea bazei standard L zero în ket u și, de asemenea, H tensorat n este propriul său transpus conjugat, deci funcționează într-un mod
similar acționând din dreapta pe bra în loc de ket. Și acum vom calcula
ce face G celor doi vectori ai noștri a0 și A1, folosind faptele pe care le-am observat tocmai.
Să începem cu a0. Mai întâi, să substituim expresia
pe care am obținut-o pentru gate-ul Z sau intercalat între două straturi de gate-uri Hadamard. Apoi putem folosi faptul că ZF nu face nimic
WEBVTT
lui ket a z, deci putem elimina operația ZF. Acum folosind descrierea
lui ket U pe care o avem sus, împreună cu faptul că ket a0 și ket A1 sunt vectori unitari ortogonali, putem calcula
produsul acestui bra cu acest ket și obținem rădăcina pătrată a numărului de non-soluții
împărțit la n. Putem folosi acest fapt pentru a evalua ce obținem și substituind expresia lui ket U și
simplificând, obținem rezultatul final arătat pe ecran. În particular, observă că acest
vector este conținut în subspațiul bidimensional generat de ket a0 și ket A1, așa cum am sugerat înainte, și
în plus coeficienții sunt numere reale. Ca întotdeauna, verifică asta în
propriul tău ritm dacă alegi să faci asta. Am tendința de a parcurge acest gen de lucruri repede în aceste videoclipuri cu
așteptarea că vei pauza videoclipul pentru a te gândi la asta dacă alegi să faci asta. Deci să curățăm asta pentru a
salva rezultatul final pentru mai târziu. Și acum vom face ceva similar pentru vectorul ket
A1. Putem folosi aceeași expresie a lui G ca înainte, iar de această dată gate-ul ZF injectează
un semn minus, care aici este reflectat de faptul că am schimbat cei doi termeni din operație în
paranteze. Procedăm apoi într-un mod foarte similar, iar rezultatul final este similar, cu excepția că cei doi coeficienți
sunt schimbați și acum avem un semn minus în fața unuia dintre ei, ceea ce este doar cum funcționează algebra. Și din nou
poți verifica asta în propriul tău ritm. Observă că din nou avem o combinație liniară reală a celor doi vectori ket a0 și
ket A1. Vom curăța și asta și vom pune rezultatul final împreună cu celălalt, iar acum putem vedea cum G
acționează pe subspațiul generat de cei doi vectori noștri. O modalitate de a face asta este să îl exprimăm în termeni de matricea 2x2 M care este
arătată pe ecran. Și pentru a fi clar ce facem: asociem primul rând și prima
coloană cu ket a0 și al doilea rând și coloana cu ket A1. Până acum în serie, am
folosit matricele pentru a descrie modul în care operațiile funcționează pe stările bazei standard, dar este obișnuit să se folosească matricele
pentru a descrie acțiunile mapărilor liniare pe diferite seturi de vectori, nu doar stările bazei standard. Și aici vorbim despre ce face operația G
vectorilor ket a0 și ket A1. Putem spune mai multe despre ce face G vectorilor din
genul lui ket a0 și ket A1 dacă aruncăm o privire mai atentă la această matrice M. Și în particular, ceea ce vom găsi este
că m este o matrice de rotație, ceea ce înseamnă că acțiunea sa pe acest spațiu bidimensional poate fi descrisă ca o rotație cu un unghi
fix. Există câteva moduri diferite de a vedea asta și una este să observăm
că această matrice M poate fi exprimată ca pătratul unei matrice care pare oarecum mai simplă. Poate fi greu de observat dacă
ne uităm doar la M, dar acesta nu este ceva ce trebuie să descoperim singuri; trebuie doar să îl verificăm, și putem face asta pur și simplu
ridicând la pătrat matricea din dreapta. O altă modalitate de a scrie matricea din dreapta, fără a include pătratul, este
arătată pe ecran, și aceasta este modalitatea tipică de a descrie o rotație cu un unghi dat Theta ca
matrice. Unghiul precis cu care rotim se întâmplă să fie arcsinusul rădăcinii pătrate a numărului de
soluții împărțit la n. Și apropo, deoarece aceasta este prima dată când îl vedem, permiteți-mi să subliniez că
acest unghi este foarte important; va continua să apară pe măsură ce continuăm această
analiză. Argumentul arcsinusului este un număr între 0 și 1, și în particular, modul în care
interpretăm arcsinusul este că este unghiul între 0 și pi/2 care ne dă argumentul când luăm
sinusul. Deci aceasta este o modalitate de a ne gândi la această matrice pe care am ridicat-o la pătrat pentru a obține
M. Și deoarece ridicarea la pătrat a matricei este același lucru cu aplicarea ei de două ori, vedem că M poate fi scris alternativ ca o
rotație nu cu un unghi de Theta, ci cu 2 * Theta, deoarece ridicând la pătrat, rotim cu un unghi de Theta
de două ori. O altă modalitate de a verifica toate acestea, apropo, în caz că este utilă, este să începem cu această expresie finală a lui M
și să folosim formulele pentru unghiuri duble din trigonometrie pentru a obține expresia originală a
lui M. Și aceasta este expresia lui M care descrie acțiunea pe care G o are pe subspațiul generat de ket a0 și ket A1, expresie ce
va fi cea mai utilă în continuare. Acum, revenind la algoritmul lui Grover însuși, după
pasul de inițializare, dar înainte de a efectua orice aplicații ale lui G, starea registrului nostru de n qubiți Q este ket u, adică
superpozitia uniformă peste toate șirurile de n biți. Și avem aceeași expresie a lui ket u în termeni de ket a0 și
ket A1 ca înainte, dar acum că am identificat acest unghi Theta, vedem că putem
alternativ scrie ket u ca cosinus Theta * ket a0 plus sinus Theta * ket
A1. Asta e clar pentru coeficientul lui ket A1, iar pentru celălalt coeficient, trebuie doar să observăm că dimensiunea lui a0 plus
dimensiunea lui A1 este n, și apoi putem obține asta din ceva trigonometrie de bază. Deci aceasta este starea cu care
începem, iar prima dată când aplicăm G, rotim cu un unghi de 2 * Theta, deci unghiul total devine 3 *
Theta. Și dacă aplicăm G din nou, unghiul crește la 5 Theta, deoarece am rotat efectiv cu un unghi suplimentar
de 2 Theta. Și tot așa, deci după T aplicații ale lui G, putem reprezenta
starea pe care o obținem după cum este arătat pe ecran, unde unghiul stării noastre este egal cu (2T + 1) * Theta, adică 2 * Theta
pentru fiecare aplicare a lui G, împreună cu un Theta suplimentar, deoarece aceasta este starea în care am început.
Putem de asemenea să ne gândim la acțiunea operației Grover în termeni geometrici, iar asta ajută să facem lumină asupra cum
funcționează și de ce efectul său este de a roti starea registrului Q. Iată ideea principală: operația Grover
este o compoziție a celor două părți pe care le-am identificat deja: una este ZF și cealaltă este z sau intercalat între
două straturi de gate-uri Hadamard. Aceste două părți sunt
reflecții, și când compunem două reflecții, obținem o rotație. Deci să vedem cum funcționează asta în
mai mult detaliu. Mai întâi, să ne concentrăm pe ZF și vom restricționa atenția la
același subspațiu bidimensional despre care am vorbit, adică cel generat de ket a0 și ket
A1. Cum am observat deja, acțiunea lui ZF pe acest spațiu este destul de simplă: nu face
nimic lui ket a z și pune un semn minus în fața lui ket A1. Aceasta este o reflecție, și în particular
WEBVTT
este o reflecție față de dreapta paralelă cu ket a0, pe care o vom numi L1, doar pentru a-i da un
nume. Pentru a vedea de ce este o reflecție, ajută să desenăm o imagine. Iată cei doi vectori ai noștri ket
a0 și ket A1, care sunt vectori unitari ortogonali, și putem să ne gândim la ecran ca constând din toate combinațiile liniare reale
ale acestor doi vectori. Deci cercul reprezintă toți vectorii unitari pentru care coeficienții
acestor doi vectori sunt numere reale. Iată dreapta L1, care este paralelă cu ket a0. Dacă considerăm un
vector arbitrar s pe acest cerc, efectul aplicării ZF este să reflecte față de această dreaptă, așa cum este ilustrat pe
ecran, pur și simplu deoarece nu facem nimic lui ket a z și punem un semn minus în fața lui ket
A1. În cazul special în care s este ket a zero, de exemplu, nu se întâmplă nimic când efectuăm această reflecție, iar când s este
ket A1, reflecția ne duce până la ket A1 negativ, ceea ce este consistent cu acțiunea lui ZF. Deci ZF este o
reflecție care poate fi vizualizată după cum avem aici. A doua parte a lui G, care este z sau
intercalat între două straturi de gate-uri Hadamard, poate fi exprimată ca 2 * ket bra u minus matricea identitate, cum
am văzut deja, și din nou aceasta este o reflecție, de această dată față de dreapta L2 paralelă cu ket u, mai degrabă decât ket
a0. Putem vizualiza această operație într-un mod similar cu ZF. Iată vectorul ket
ipotetic, deci aceasta este dreapta L2 paralelă cu ket u, iar din nou acțiunea pe un vector arbitrar s este să îl reflecte
față de dreapta, care este L2 în acest caz.
Și în final, cum am menționat înainte, ori de câte ori compunem două reflecții, obținem o rotație, și în particular este
o rotație cu de două ori unghiul dintre dreptele de reflecție. Deci să desenăm o imagine similară
cu cea de dinainte. Iată dreptele de reflecție, care au unghiul Theta între
ele. Dacă luăm un vector arbitrar s, reflectat față de prima dreaptă L1 și
apoi reflectat față de a doua dreaptă L2, efectul net va fi de a roti vectorul s cu un unghi de de două ori Theta.
Iar asta este ceva adevărat în general, și poți încerca pe alte exemple suplimentare pentru a vedea că acesta este într-adevăr modul în care
funcționează. Oricum, sperăm că asta te ajută să obții o intuiție despre de ce operația Grover are efectul de a roti
vectori. Urmează să abordăm problema alegerii numărului de iterații T în algoritmul lui Grover.
Să începem prin a ne gândi la cum se leagă analiza pe care am văzut-o până acum, care dezvăluie ce face operația Grover
când o aplicăm în mod repetat superpozitiei uniforme, cu sarcina pe care sperăm să o rezolvăm, adică să găsim o soluție la problema noastră de căutare
sau altfel spus orice șir conținut în mulțimea A1. Pe scurt, practic vom stabili
o țintă și apoi vom calcula de câte ori să aplicăm operația Grover pentru a ne apropia de această
țintă. Mai întâi să ne imaginăm că avem orice stare care este o combinație liniară a celor doi vectori ai noștri ket a0 și ket
A1. Dacă efectuăm o măsurătoare în baza standard pe această stare, vom obține un rezultat în mulțimea A1, care este
mulțimea soluțiilor la problema noastră de căutare, cu probabilitate egală cu valoarea absolută la pătrat a oricărui coeficient pe care îl avem pentru ket A1. Și pentru
vectorul arătat pe ecran, acel coeficient este beta. Asta este intuitiv: dacă am măsura starea ket a0,
am obține o non-soluție aleatoare, iar dacă am măsura ket A1, am obține o soluție aleatoare. Deci dacă măsurăm această stare
de aici, vom obține o non-soluție aleatoare cu probabilitate valoarea absolută a lui Alpha la pătrat și o soluție aleatoare
cu probabilitate valoarea absolută a lui beta la pătrat. Dar putem de asemenea să ne oprim un moment pentru a o calcula. Iată starea scrisă
detaliat ca să putem vedea care sunt intrările acestui vector pentru stările bazei standard. Deci dacă măsurăm, acestea sunt
probabilitățile de a obține fiecare rezultat posibil, iar pentru a obține probabilitatea de a obține o soluție, sumăm
probabilitățile pentru toate soluțiile posibile, ceea ce ne dă valoarea absolută a lui beta la pătrat, după cum
era de așteptat. Acum am analizat deja ce se întâmplă când rulăm algoritmul lui Grover pentru T iterații; obținem starea
arătată pe ecran. Deci deoarece coeficientul lui ket A1 este sinusul
lui (2T + 1) * Theta, unde din nou iată acest unghi foarte important Theta,
vom vedea o soluție cu probabilitate sin² de (2T+1) *
Theta. Am vrea să facem această probabilitate mare, ideal cât mai aproape de unu. Deci pe măsură ce rotim vectorul stare
iterând G, ne vom gândi la ket A1 ca la starea țintă și vom încerca
să alegem T astfel încât să ajungem aproape de această stare. Și pe măsură ce facem asta, este bine să avem în minte că am vrea de asemenea să
minimizăm T, deoarece acesta este numărul de interogări pe care trebuie să le facem. Deci, dacă vrem să facem această
probabilitate aproape de unu și să minimizăm T, are sens să încercăm să facem unghiul vectorului nostru stare aproape de pi/2, deoarece
acesta este cel mai mic unghi care face ca pătratul sinusului să fie mare, deci practic este prima noastră oportunitate de a face probabilitatea mare pe măsură ce
rotim vectorul stare. Acum nu putem neapărat atinge exact acest unghi pi pe doi, deoarece T trebuie
să fie un număr întreg, dar dacă ne gândim la asta aproximativ și rezolvăm pentru t ca și cum ar fi o inegalitate, vedem că ideal
alegerea lui T ca pi peste 4 * Theta minus 1/2 are
sens. Dar desigur T trebuie să fie un număr întreg non-negativ, deci ce vom face este să
luăm cel mai apropiat număr întreg de ceea ce ne imaginăm că este această valoare ideală, adică podeaua lui pi împărțit la 4 *
Theta. A lua podeaua înseamnă, apropo, că aruncăm orice parte fracționară, deci altfel spus, este cel mai mare
număr întreg mai mic sau egal cu valoarea din care luăm podeaua. Conform acestei expresii, dacă
valoarea ideală se întâmplă să fie la jumătatea distanței dintre numere întregi, vom rotunji în sus, dar asta nu va conta deloc pentru
scopul acestei lecții. Deci de acum înainte ne vom concentra pe această alegere particulară a
lui T. Dar există o altă considerație importantă pe care trebuie să o facem, și anume că această specificație a lui T depinde
de câte soluții există, deoarece unghiul Theta depinde de numărul de
soluții. De acum înainte voi folosi litera s pentru a mă referi la numărul de soluții sau altfel spus dimensiunea
mulțimii A1, doar de dragul comodității. Oricum, ideea este că expresia noastră
pentru T, valoarea pe care o ipotezăm că ar trebui să fie bună, depinde de Theta, iar Theta depinde de S, care este
WEBVTT
dimensiunea mulțimii A1. Aceasta nu este o problemă dacă știm în avans câte soluții există, dar
dacă nu știm câte soluții există în avans, nu știm ce este Theta, deci nu putem alege T astfel.
Și va trebui să facem ceva diferit. Mă voi întoarce la situația în care nu știm s puțin mai târziu, dar pentru
început, să ne concentrăm pe situația în care știm câte soluții există, începând cu căutarea unică
unde există garantat o singură soluție unică pe care o căutăm.
Am menționat problema căutării unice ca exemplu de problemă de interogare înapoi în lecția
cinci. Intrarea este o funcție f de la n biți la un bit; există un unic șir de n biți
care face ca f să se evalueze la unu, iar scopul este să afișăm acel șir. Deci
aceasta este echivalentă cu problema de căutare nestructurată despre care am vorbit, dar cu promisiunea că există exact o soluție. Și de fapt aceasta este
singura versiune a problemei de căutare pe care a considerat-o Lov Grover în articolul său original din 1996, care a introdus algoritmul lui Grover.
Pentru căutarea unică avem că s este egal cu 1, și prin urmare acest unghi important Theta este egal cu arcsinusul
din rădăcina pătrată a lui 1/n. Când n este mare, această valoare este aproximativ rădăcina pătrată din 1/N, și
asta deoarece pentru unghiuri tot mai mici, funcția sinus începe să arate tot mai mult ca funcția identitate.
Dacă substituim acea aproximare în selecția noastră pentru T, vedem că t este aproximativ podeaua
lui pi peste 4 * rădăcina din n. Asta e bine, deoarece suntem pe drumul cel bun să folosim O mare din rădăcina pătrată din n
interogări, deși în acest punct nu am analizat încă exact cât de bine performează algoritmul.
Să analizăm un exemplu în care N mare este 128, adică 2 la puterea 7. Deci
funcția noastră f este de la șapte biți la un bit, și presupunem că există o soluție unică. Dar pentru a afla cât de
bine funcționează algoritmul, trebuie să ne ocupăm doar de unghiul Theta, pe care îl putem calcula:
este aproximativ 0,0885 radiani, adică un pic mai mult de 5°. Și dacă introducem acea valoare în
expresia noastră pentru T, obținem opt. Deci ne gândim la ce se întâmplă când căutăm o soluție unică din 128 de
posibilități folosind opt interogări. Putem desena o imagine pentru a ilustra cum se schimbă starea în timp
pe măsură ce efectuăm iterații ale operației Grover. Ca și înainte, avem stările ket
a0 și ket A1, iar în acest caz particular, adică căutarea unică, ket A1 este de fapt starea bazei standard
corespunzând soluției unice, oricare ar fi ea. Ei bine, ket a0 este superpozitia uniformă peste toate
șirurile în afară de soluția unică. Iată superpozitia uniformă peste toate șirurile, pe care
o putem scrie ca cosinus Theta ket a0 plus sinus Theta ket A1, și are sens că ket a0
și ket U sunt apropiate în acest caz, deoarece cum am observat tocmai acum ket a0 este
aproape superpozitia uniformă peste toate șirurile; lipsește doar un șir, și acela este soluția unică. Aplicarea lui G din nou rotește cu un
Theta suplimentar de 2 Theta, deci iată unde ne aflăm după două iterații. Iată trei, patru, cinci, șase, șapte și opt.
Și acum vedem că suntem destul de aproape de ket A1, deci dacă ne oprim și măsurăm în acest punct, vom fi destul de probabil să obținem
soluția unică. Și de fapt în acest caz există doar circa jumătate de procent șansă că nu obținem soluția
unică. Pe de altă parte, dacă am continua să aplicăm operația Grover de mai mult de cele opt ori recomandate,
atunci probabilitatea de a obține o soluție ar scădea din nou, iar în timp ar oscila pe măsură ce starea se deplasează
în jurul cercului. Deci este important că ne oprim iterațiile la momentul potrivit dacă vrem să reușim cu probabilitate
mare. Să ne gândim la probabilitatea că alegerea noastră pentru T dezvăluie soluția unică mai general, pentru diferite valori ale
lui n. Vom scrie p(n,1) pentru a denota probabilitatea ca algoritmul lui Grover să reușească să găsească o soluție unică
pentru fiecare valoare posibilă a lui n. Unu înseamnă o soluție, și vom extinde această notație la alte numere de soluții
în curând. Iată un tabel cu aceste probabilități pentru puteri mici ale lui doi. Începe cu n=2 și
probabilitatea este 1/2, ceea ce nu este foarte bine. Dar pentru n=4, probabilitatea este exact unu, deci funcționează
perfect în acest caz. Este un exercițiu excelent, apropo, să parcurgi explicit cum funcționează aceste două cazuri,
în special cazul n egal cu patru. În acel caz, căutăm o soluție din patru posibilități,
avem nevoie de o singură interogare și funcționează perfect. Pe măsură ce n crește, vedem unele fluctuații, probabilitățile
cresc și scad un pic, dar par să se apropie de unu, și într-adevăr este adevărat. Poate fi demonstrat
analitic că probabilitatea este întotdeauna cel puțin 1 - 1/n. Deci asta e bine:
algoritmul nu este perfect, nu avem garantată o soluție, dar este destul de probabil, în special pentru valori mari
ale lui n, precum și anomalia foarte interesantă care apare când n este egal cu 4.
Trebuie de asemenea să subliniez că putem rula întotdeauna întregul algoritm, inclusiv măsurătorile, de câte ori alegem, iar dacă vreuna dintre rulări
reușește, vom obține o soluție. Deci dacă aceste probabilități nu sunt suficient de bune, le putem crește ușor rulând din nou
algoritmul. De fapt, chiar dacă aceste probabilități ar fi toate egale cu 1/2, de exemplu, am mai avea tot un
algoritm de căutare util. Acum să considerăm ce se întâmplă când există soluții multiple.
Vom începe cu un exemplu similar cu cel de dinainte: din nou n este egal cu 128, dar de această dată numărul
de soluții s este patru în loc de 1. Din nou putem calcula Theta și T și
obținem că Theta este aproximativ 0,1777, sau un bit mai mult de 10°, iar T este
patru de această dată. Deci unghiul este aproximativ de două ori valoarea din exemplul anterior, iar T este jumătate din ce era.
Putem desena o imagine ca mai înainte. Iată unde
începem, iată o iterație, două, trei și patru. De această dată suntem foarte aproape de ket
A1, iar probabilitatea de a obține o soluție de această dată se dovedește a fi mai mare de
99,9%. Dar dacă nu am ști mai bine și am crede că există o singură soluție, am lua T ca 8 ca
mai înainte, am roti aproape tot drumul spre ket a0 negativ, și asta ar duce la o probabilitate de
succes foarte mică. Deci acesta este un alt exemplu care arată că există alegeri bune ale lui T și alegeri rele ale lui T, și iată vedem
WEBVTT
că o alegere bună pentru s egal cu 1 se dovedește a fi o alegere foarte proastă pentru s egal cu 4. Dar presupunând că știm s în
avans și alegem T conform specificației noastre, atunci se dovedește că algoritmul lui Grover va găsi o soluție
cu probabilitate cel puțin 1 - s/n, și adesea va fi mult mai mare decât asta. Este de asemenea cel puțin s/N, dar
asta este mult mai puțin interesant. Ceea ce este mai interesant este că pe măsură ce fracția s/N devine mică, limita inferioară
privind probabilitatea de succes se apropie tot mai mult de unu. Acum, după cum am remarcat deja de mai multe ori,
numărul T reprezintă nu numai numărul de iterații ale operației Grover pe care le efectuăm, ci și numărul
de interogări pe care le facem. Deci cum depinde acest număr de s și
n? Mai întâi să începem cu faptul că arcsinusul lui x este întotdeauna cel puțin x, cu condiția că x este între zero și 1.
Asta este destul de ușor de demonstrat dacă se întâmplă să cunoști seria Taylor pentru funcția arcsin, dar există și alte moduri de a argumenta, și vom
accepta asta ca adevărat. Asta înseamnă că Theta este cel puțin rădăcina din s/
n, și prin urmare T este cel mult pi/4 * rădăcina din n/
s. Deci asta este chiar mai bine decât O mare din rădăcina lui n: cu cât s este mai mare în
comparație cu n, cu atât mai puține interogări trebuie să facem. Și într-un fel nu este surprinzător că această fracție apare
astfel, dat că reciproca ei definește Theta, iar la final Theta este cu adevărat tot ce contează pentru
această analiză. Cum tocmai am văzut, algoritmul lui Grover funcționează destul de bine când știm
în avans câte soluții există. Dar ce facem dacă nu știm câte soluții
există? Există o abordare destul de simplă, și aceea este să alegem numărul de iterații
aleatoriu, și în particular, alegând T uniform aleatoriu între unu și podeaua lui pi/4 * rădăcina din n se dovedește că este
o modalitate destul de bună de a face asta. Capătul superior al acestui interval este aproximativ numărul de interogări pe care l-am alege pentru căutarea unică, și de fapt
este exact numărul potrivit în majoritatea cazurilor. Acesta este atunci când unghiul Theta este cât mai mic posibil, excluzând
cazul trivial când nu există soluții. Ideea este că, în loc să vizăm cu grijă vectorul nostru stare la
ket A1 cum am făcut când știam câte soluții există, practic rotim cu un unghi aleatoriu, ca și cum i-am da
vectorului stare o rotație aleatorie. Dacă se întâmplă să existe o singură soluție, rotația noastră aleatorie ar putea împinge
vectorul stare aproape de ket A1, dar ar putea de asemenea doar să ajungă parțial acolo. Iar dacă se întâmplă să existe multe soluții, atunci
rotația aleatorie ar putea potențial trimite vectorul stare în jurul cercului de mai multe ori. Deci nu ne așteptăm ca asta să dezvăluie
o soluție cu o probabilitate aproape de unu, dar șansa că asta duce la o soluție dacă există una se dovedește a fi
destul de bună: este întotdeauna cel puțin 40%. De fapt, asta nu este evident, dar este
cazul. Cu siguranță nu este șocant, deoarece un unghi cu adevărat aleatoriu ar avea o șansă de 50% de a găsi o
soluție. Oricum, 40% nu este rău, și ține minte că putem crește întotdeauna probabilitatea de a găsi o soluție
repetând procesul, alegând T independent de fiecare dată. Făcând asta, șansele de a nu
găsi o soluție când există una scad exponențial cu numărul de ori în care repetăm. Deci dacă vrem o șansă de 99%
de a găsi o soluție, ce putem face este să rulăm această abordare simplă de 10 ori, din nou cu t ales independent de fiecare
dată. Desigur, dacă nu găsim o soluție, afișăm că nu există soluții. Dacă nu există soluții,
nu vom găsi una, deci în acel caz vom afișa întotdeauna răspunsul corect, care este că nu există soluții. Dacă există soluții,
am putea eșua să găsim una și să declarăm incorect că nu există soluții, dar probabilitatea că se întâmplă asta poate fi făcută foarte mică.
Avem de asemenea, cum am menționat cu câteva momente în urmă, că aceasta necesită un număr de interogări sau evaluări ale lui f de O mare din rădăcina
lui n. Deci folosind algoritmul lui Grover putem totuși rezolva problema de căutare cu probabilitate mare cu O mare din rădăcina lui n
interogări, chiar dacă nu știm în avans câte soluții există. Există de asemenea o abordare mai sofisticată
care poate duce la o reducere a numărului de interogări pe măsură ce crește numărul de soluții. Nu o voi descrie în
detaliu, ci mă voi concentra doar pe ideea principală. Începem cu T capital egal
cu unu. Rulăm apoi algoritmul lui Grover pentru un număr aleatoriu de iterații, dar unde limita superioară este T. Deci prima
dată când ajungem la pasul doi, vom rula algoritmul lui Grover cu o singură iterație, dar T va
crește. Dacă găsim o soluție, afișăm acea soluție și ne oprim. Dacă nu găsim o soluție, facem T
mai mare și încercăm din nou. Și la un moment dat, înainte ca T să devină prea mare, vom termina procesul și
vom declara că nu există soluții. Este aceeași idee de bază ca în abordarea simplă, în care dăm
vectorului stare rotații aleatoare, esențial, dar aici începem cu rotații mai ușoare mai întâi, când T este
mic, în caz că există o mulțime de soluții. În acest fel nu vom irosi interogări făcând starea să se rotească
în jurul cercului rotind prea tare. Dar dacă nu funcționează, adică dacă nu găsim o soluție, încercăm din nou
dar rotim un pic mai tare sau potențial un pic mai tare. Pentru ca asta să funcționeze, rata de
creștere a lui T trebuie aleasă cu atenție, iar o modalitate de a face asta este să înlocuim T cu plafonul lui 5/4 ori T.
Deci T crește exponențial și intuitiv ne putem gândi la asta ca rotind cu 25% mai tare de fiecare
dată. Și este important pentru analiză că T crește exponențial astfel. De ce 5/4? Ai putea întreba. Ei bine, este
pur și simplu un număr care funcționează, și există de fapt un interval de valori care funcționează, dar de exemplu, 2 nu funcționează: dublarea lui T
de fiecare dată este o creștere prea rapidă pentru a profita pe deplin de beneficiile rotațiilor mai ușoare. Oricum, scopul acestei metode mai
sofisticate este că dă aceeași limită asimptotică privind numărul de interogări necesare ca mai înainte:
O mare din rădăcina din n/s. Dar nu trebuie să știm în avans câte soluții există. Și apropo,
putem opri acest proces când T ajunge la rădăcina din n, deci dacă nu există soluții, vom ajunge la această concluzie după O mare
din rădăcina din n interogări. Și acesta este modul în care putem alege numărul de iterații în algoritmul lui Grover. Pentru a încheia lecția, voi
face doar câteva remarci scurte despre algoritmul lui Grover. Mai întâi, în cadrul modelului de interogare,
algoritmul lui Grover este asimptotic optimal. Ceea ce înseamnă asta este că nu este posibil să vii cu un
algoritm de interogare pentru rezolvarea problemei de căutare sau chiar a problemei de căutare unică în particular, care folosește asimptotic
WEBVTT
mai puțin de O mare din rădăcina din n interogări în cel mai rău caz. Asta este ceva ce poate fi demonstrat riguros
și există de fapt mai multe demonstrații cunoscute ale acestui fapt. Interesant, asta era cunoscut chiar
înainte ca algoritmul lui Grover să fie descoperit. Algoritmul lui Grover a corespuns limitei inferioare deja cunoscute privind numărul de
interogări necesare. Din când în când, oamenii vin cu abordări despre care cred că sunt asimptotic
superioare algoritmului lui Grover, dar există întotdeauna fie o greșeală, fie o presupunere despre funcția f și
modul în care poate fi accesată, sau o altă problemă care face afirmația incorectă. Dacă lucrezi corect
în cadrul modelului de interogare, nu poți bate algoritmul lui Grover pentru căutarea nestructurată. Al doilea punct: algoritmul lui Grover este
aplicabil pe scară largă în sensul că accelerarea cu rădăcina pătrată pe care algoritmul lui Grover o oferă pentru problema de căutare nestructurată poate fi
obținută într-o varietate de setări diferite. De exemplu, uneori este posibil să se folosească algoritmul lui Grover
deasupra unui alt algoritm pentru a obține o îmbunătățire cuadratică față de performanța acelui algoritm. Algoritmul lui Grover este de asemenea
destul de des folosit ca subrutină în alți algoritmi cuantici. Ca un exemplu simplu, putem
folosi algoritmul lui Grover pentru a obține un avantaj cuadratic față de algoritmii clasici pentru problema minimului pe care am menționat-o în
lecția cinci. Și în final, tehnica folosită în algoritmul lui Grover, în care avem două
reflecții care sunt compuse și iterate pentru a roti un vector stare cuantic, poate fi generalizată într-un mod destul de
important. Un exemplu este o tehnică cunoscută sub numele de amplificare a amplitudinii, în care un proces
ce generalizează algoritmul lui Grover poate fi aplicat unui alt algoritm cuantic pentru a-i crește esențial probabilitatea de succes cuadratic mai rapid decât ar fi
posibil clasic, iar acea tehnică are aplicații largi în algoritmii cuantici. Deci poate fi adevărat că
algoritmul lui Grover nu este probabil să ducă la un avantaj cuantic practic în curând, dacă vreodată, dar algoritmul lui Grover este
fără îndoială un algoritm cuantic fundamental important și larg aplicabil, reprezentativ pentru o tehnică mai generală cu multe
utilizări. Și asta e tot pentru această lecție și pentru această unitate a seriei, care a tratat algoritmii cuantici.
Am discutat modelul de interogare și cum îl putem conecta la un model standard de computație, împreună cu
alte câteva concepte fundamentale privind cum putem măsura costul computațional. Am acoperit apoi estimarea fazei
și factorizarea, iar în final algoritmul lui Grover. Cum am sugerat deja,
există mult mai mult de învățat despre algoritmii cuantici, dar în această serie vom trece la un subiect diferit în unitatea următoare. În particular, vom examina
formularea generală a informației cuantice, în care stările cuantice sunt reprezentate de matrice de un anumit
tip, cunoscute ca matrice de densitate. Cum vom vedea, această formulare se dovedește a fi foarte utilă și într-adevăr
esențială pentru înțelegerea unor aspecte ale informației cuantice, și se întâmplă să fie destul de frumoasă din punct de vedere
matematic. Deci sper că te vei alătura mie pentru unitatea trei și la revedere până
atunci.